what is happening there reject nation
what is good you got my buddy aaron here
with me today there was a word on the
street that there'd be a
special look at loki during an nba game
we found it on twitter
hopefully this can stay up on youtube
[Laughter]
hopefully it's fine here yeah it'll be
fine it's only like 50 seconds i'm glad
you drove 25 minutes to come here today
air
any time i will drive a thousand miles
greg
so you just see you and not get
demonetized i need to get us to my touch
right now
i said it's slow pick up on that and
thanks for helping us go trending
earlier today guys
thank you means a lot anywho let's get
into action people
and now a special look at marvel studios
original series
[Music]
[Music]
unbelievable wherever
[Laughter]
i feel like that's gonna be the best one
of the three this year it looks really
good i really
am under the impression it will be odin
wilson and and tom hilson are just so
charismatic it seems like we're getting
a lot of really random really cool
historical stuff in there
yeah i mean you see like with the the
events of pompeii but i got a little bit
more
this time around during this specific
one was owen wilson's mobius character
how he really seems to be rooting that
loki does good
yeah that's better because there were
some vibes in the other trailers where i
wasn't sure
if is he just pulling some strings is he
being just kind of
is he trying to manipulate the
manipulator but it really seems like
because they have these
behind-the-scenes uh conversations that
he's having with other tva members here
of like no just
give him a chance give the guy a chance
but he's but i feel like he's being
pushed to the edge because
loki is not cooperating yeah loki's not
playing the game
uh he would like the way he'd like loki
to play so it's kind of the vibe that
i'm getting with it
yeah it looks like they're definitely
gonna have some semblance of uh do i
trust them do i not kind of relationship
and loki
just been like you can trust me yeah
trust me
[Laughter]
also in addition to seeing whatever
cameos and what other
intrigue and more development into the
marvel cinematic universe
that we do see looks like we're going to
get more cosmic maybe get a little
variations in the history that we know
in the marvel cinematic universe and how
they change that up from my
understanding is that
you know because you have like images of
him as like president loki you have
images of him as uh d.b
cooper that most likely is actually
different
loki's that we're looking at that it's
not the same
it's not just this one loki who we're
watching have all this fun and mischief
this loki is a variant
who we're watching the one from endgame
right not the
main prime time location
what the actual terminology is that loki
died in infinity war
and then this loki from endgame he's his
variant is what they call him as
so i think what we're looking at are
other variants of loki's and he's kind
of
meddling into or like trying to help fix
the timeline
and such that i feel like what he did
causes huge disruption
and now we've got all these other loki's
doing all kinds of crazy things you know
wow
i really like that that's a really cool
theory a loki team up like all the
different
variations of loki i think it would help
better explain a lot of like the random
variety of the situations that we're
seeing here
like we could have seen this like end
game but it's just all loki
loki's coming through the portals one
thing that i find very consistent with
the marketing of this and but especially
that i think is captured in this
this like awesome little bubble in this
one tv spot loki is the god of mischief
and it just
feels like the mayhem is just gonna
escalate that he's gonna create all
these enemies along the way
it looks like only mobius oh owen
wilson's the only one who really
has faith in him within the tva but the
tva is gonna be hunting him down
as well like this just feels like it's
gonna slowly
i don't know how slowly is the right
word but eventually it's just gonna
become like the
ultimate catastrophe by the end and for
it being the god of mischief
i love the idea of his mischievous ways
leading to
utter chaos by the end of it all yeah
you know what it reminds me of one of
those shows that
has like this organization like some
sort of government facility or whatever
they
bring on this wild card to help them
with a case that only specifically this
person can help them with
i think it's that but the msu's wild
more universe engaging version of that
and i think because
we're familiar with the character of
loki and we're familiar with the mcu and
the different branches and varieties
that the universe has
unfolded to us so far we're gonna get a
lot more of that those two things
intertwining
is gonna really create some some
fascinating and some bananas
events that'll probably affect the mcu
in the future
it seems like they've been focusing on
very specific things that they're
cutting to
db cooper this one that looks like an
alternate timeline where loki may have
won
after the avengers movie it seems like
they've become kind of a similar
historical events
so like what historical events have they
not cut to that they have in store for
us
like that's what i'm i'm most anxious to
see with something like juan division or
with something like falcon winter
soldier
obviously we don't know what the exact
journey is but we can pretty much
surmise that it's going to end with a
big superhero fight you know the hero's
going to win
loki's traditionally a villain or an
anti-hero
yeah so the fact that we're seeing a
true
wild card in this universe i have no
clue
what they're gonna do for an ending to
this and also the fact that
we are seeing these different things
take place over the course of history
where loki has kind of intervened or
involved in some way
it gives marvel the creative freedom to
do something akin to like
quentin tarantino where he like can take
something historical and really twist it
on his head
yeah or they can really twist it on
their head and really have fun with it
like the db cooper thing or like the
pompeii thing and also you know like
this being the last
show before we go into the start like
really
going into the movies then because like
they're getting getting all their shows
out of the way then we got the movies
coming king the conqueror is supposed to
be
uh the villain in ant-man quantomania
and ravona renslayer who's the the
this is like the what's been reported i
don't know if it's a hundred percent
confirmed or not the way she's being
kind of portrayed makes you
sort of think that ravona renslayer
supposedly is this woman who
owen wilson's talking to in this trailer
the one who's like i don't trust loki
and he looks like he's going to get to a
holiday with him she is of like romantic
interest or
an object of affection per se for uh
king the conqueror
and it looks like there's some events
here that will tie directly to king the
conqueror as well
so you know i mean this this could be
one that heavily connects to
the upcoming craziness of the
multiverses and the cosmicness and
and all that jazz you know okay
interesting yeah i never thought about
that
that's okay i mean and this is the most
she's featured in this trailer
out of all the other trailers this is
the even though it's the shortest one
this is the most she's been featured
wow so i feel like they want us to pay
attention to her i think that is super
cool i
really really hope that you're right and
they do tie those things together i mean
yeah it's something that i've heard
all right guys well loki are you excited
for the show leave your thoughts down
below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
aaron thanks for swinging on bye on your
way over to the pet store yep woof woof
i went with pet store today
i don't know why that was my go-to it's
okay i i don't know why i wolfed
deontay w tongue punch fart box
exactly that what's good my good sir if
there's anyone who is mischievous
at our patreon page it's got to be this
guy
it's you constantly sticking his tongue
and fart boxes all around the world
but also i wanted to make sure to shout
him out today because
aaron according to our shout out here
he is the token black guy at our patreon
page
wow and you being
you know what a friendly gentleman yeah
i don't need to go further
i'm gonna i think i i caught myself he
caught himself
i caught i caught myself tongue punch
fart box let's just stick
to that i was i was really hoping he's
gonna he's gonna finish it but i i got
it i got it for you mr fartbox
you and me we're my only two black
friends your only two black friends
who's tyro magnus i don't know but he's
my long distance black friend
right you're in categories that's right
that's right you know man we
we appreciate you for being here for
subscribing i know you're here for him
maybe you like me too i don't know man i
i've i just heard of you
greg is he'll be racist oh wait you
can't
[ __ ] really trying to be
cultured right now go go home greg okay
i'm sorry everyone
every month all i have to work with is
tongue punch box
sorry i'm trying